schools in the majority of states will
not reopen for the remainder of the
academic year and many parents say they
are already overwhelmed by the
alternative remote learning a recent
survey found nearly 50% of parents are
struggling to keep kids focused on
schoolwork while at home and nearly 40%
say they are also juggling their own
jobs with their children's schooling meg
Oliver spoke to teachers and parents it
seems like the worlds yes Alison
Ferrante is overwhelmed trying to
balance it all when you look at your
kids to do just to make you break down
yes and it's crazy because their
kindergarten and second-grade Ferrante
is a seventh grade math teacher in
Queens New York an area hit hard by the
virus she worries about her students
beyond their education her husband is an
emergency room physician assistant
adding another layer of stress to the
family dynamic education it's high up
there because it does give you something
to focus on a little less work never
stops work never stops
it is around-the-clock and Nisha Warner
is an eighth grade teacher in New York
City and a single mom to her
six-year-old son I am everything I am
his support system
I am his lunch lady I am his I'm his
teacher
I'm Warner said on days when her job is
more demanding she needs to scale back
her son's work I can't even imagine a
parent who is not a teacher at all
getting all of these materials currently
schools in 36 states and the District of
Columbia have been ordered to remain
closed the rest of the academic year
that's around 33 million public school
students students like Lunetta Wilson's
three young children in Fort Worth Texas
they've been remote learning since
mid-march Wilson said at first balancing
her job as a social worker with her
children's education was incredibly
difficult at
she came up with a daily schedule the
routine started to gel I'm gonna do my
part to make sure that they're where
they need to be academically but you
can't school psychologist Brandon gamble
agrees he said the most important thing
right now for families is just taking
time to be together you're not well and
it's difficult for your children to be
well so take that time they stay on the
airplane get that oxygen mask for
yourself first
basically my computer on all day
Ferrante says exercise reduces her
stress but that can only go so far when
I do call parents of my own students
like I really tell them I understand
what they're going through even harder I
know I can get through the rest of the
school year I hope we have our summer at
least to recuperate looking forward to
that break now some school districts are
sending out surveys like this one that
my children's school sent trying to get
a pulse on how parents are coping my
favorite question on here
what are we grateful for during this
time it's something psychologists say we
have to keep asking ourselves Tony yeah
indeed I know we're saying some parents
may feel overwhelmed that trying to
balance work and teaching their kids
remotely but I gotta think it's more
like all parents perfection is not
possible everybody's struggling the same
way you are I think we all just need to
go easy on each other and redefine what
it means to learn in this period there
are alternative ways to take in the
world around you very difficult but
enriching in its own way as well Meg
thank you very much